- Good morning Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is Believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the major
problems in the world.
So today's message is work on yourself.
Over to you, Oprah Winfrey.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I say to my girls all of
the time, that your real work
is to figure out where your power base is
and to work on the alignment
of your personality,
your gifts, that you have to give
with the real reason why you're here,
that's the number one
thing, you have to do
is to work on yourself
and to fill yourself up
and keep your cup full,
keep yourself full.
Now, I used to be afraid of
that, I used to be afraid,
particularly from people who say,
"Oh, she's so full of herself,
"mm, she's so full of herself,"
and now I embrace it,
I consider it a compliment,
that I am full of myself,
because you only when you're full,
I'm full, I'm overflowing,
my cup runneth over,
I've so much, I have so much
to offer and so much to give
and I am not afraid of
honoring myself, you know,
it's miraculous when you think about it.
- I really love how Oprah Winfrey
turned what was intended as a negative,
but being full of yourself
and she turns that into a positive,
and I think it's such a
necessary skill as entrepreneurs,
to take negative things and
find the positivity in it,
to find the optimism in it,
to find the solutions in it,
'cause that's how we
stand out and succeed.
I also really agree with
the point on developing
and working on yourself and
this is working it really hard,
it's easy to say I'm
going to work on myself,
it's easy to say I'm going to
work on improving this new skill
or learning that new language
or building that new business,
or whatever it is that
you want to go out and do,
it's easy to say, but
it's hard to execute,
it's hard to execute because chances are,
you're the only one in your environment,
that actually cares about it,
like say you want to be a YouTuber,
you look at these YouTubes and
say, "I want to be a YouTuber,
"I want to build a business on YouTube,
"I want to have a impact,
"I have a message, that needs to come out,
"I want to get my
YouTube channel started."
Chances are, you're the only person,
that you know, who wants to do YouTube
and so it can be hard to stay motivated,
because the people around you,
some of them may be negative,
some of them may be saying,
"Well, you can't do that,
"you've never gone to school for that,
"what makes you think you
can create a YouTube channel,
"are you kidding me, do
you know who you are?"
That's great, some people may be negative,
some people though may just not care
and some people may be encouraging,
but no matter how encouraging they are,
you are the one who cares
the most about this dream
and when you don't have
the people around you,
who are also doing the same thing,
especially at a higher level than you are,
it can be really hard to
continue and stay motivated,
and what happens then is you have a day,
when you're motivated, you're
off, you're working hard,
you're creating your channel,
you want to make a new video
and then you wake up the next day like,
that momentum has gone,
you say, "Who am I to make
a video, I'm not very good,
"did you see what I did
yesterday, that was terrible,"
and then you get inspired
by something else,
maybe you watch a video and
then you're on fire again,
like, "I'm going to make another video,"
and you go off and you create
it and then you fall off,
and so this constant up
and down, rollercoaster,
yo yo, you know, up and down,
never really getting any consistency in it
and so the key for me,
when there's something that
you really want to work on,
that nobody else in your
environment cares about,
is putting it into your
calendar and scheduling it out.
If you goal is to have success on YouTube,
as an example, or insert
whatever you goal is,
then schedule it out, make
time for it every single day,
that you're spending time
building your skills,
learning the language of that
industry to get better at it,
honing your craft, because on
the days where you're on fire
and motivated, you won't need
to schedule, you'll just be,
you'll blast through it and
just have tons of productivity,
but on the off days, on the
days in between those spikes,
the schedule helps you stay committed
to the goal that you have,
the schedule helps you stay on path,
even when you don't have
a stronger motivation to do the work
and so I would look at,
what are your big goals?
What is it that you want to accomplish?
How do you want to work on yourself?
And then look at your calendar
and do the things in your
calendar mapped to your ambition?
Are you doing the work
in your daily calendar,
that will help you achieve your goals,
because for too many people, it's not,
too many have these big goals
and then you look at how
they're spending their time,
they don't match up,
the work they're doing consistently
is not going to help get
them to where they want to go
and so those days of
inspiration are amazing,
but if you want to continue the process
and actually make real progress towards
achieving your goals and
really building yourself up,
then you have to schedule it in
and make time for it to happen.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
what is a daily non-negotiable for you?
What do you schedule into
your calendar every day,
at least during the week, weekdays,
that has to happen every
day, non-negotiable,
I'm curious to find out,
leave it down in the Comments below.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Margarita from
Lovesomi.com, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
I really, really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoy the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you can continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
I will see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
(clicking typewriter keys)
- I spoke at an education
summit for Microsoft,
I also spoke at an
education summit for Apple.
At the education summit for Microsoft,
I would say that 70% of the executives
spent about 70% of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple.
At the Apple education
summit, 100% of the executives
spent 100% of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn.
One is playing this way and
one is playing that way.
One is playing finite and the
other one is playing infinite,
guess which one gets frustrated?
(audience laughing)
So at the end of my talk at Microsoft,
they gave me a gift, they
gave me the new Zune,
when it was a thing
(audience laughing)
and let me tell ya, this
thing was spectacular,
it was the most elegant piece
of technology I'd ever used,
the user interface was incredible,
the design was spectacular,
I absolutely loved it,
it was easy to use and it
was bright and gorgeous and,
it didn't work on Itunes,
which is a different problem,
so I couldn't use it, but it was amazing
(audience laughing)
and elegant, my God, it was elegant.
So I'm sitting in the back of a taxi
with a very senior, Apple executive,
sort of employee number 12 kind of guy
and you know, I like to stir pots,
so I turned to him and I said, "You know,
"Microsoft gave me their new Zune
"and it is so much better
than your Ipod Touch,"
and he turned to me and he
said, "I have no doubt,"
conversation over,
(audience laughing)
because the infinite player understands,
sometimes you're ahead and
sometimes you're behind,
sometimes your product is
better and sometimes its worse.
The goal isn't to be the best every day,
the goal isn't to outdo
your competition every day,
that's a finite construction.
If I had said to Microsoft,
"I've got the new Ipod Touch
"and it's so much better than your Zune,"
they would have said, "Can
we see it, what does it do?"
react, react, react.
Finite players play to beat
the people around them,
infinite players play to
be better than themselves,
to wake up every single day and say,
"How can we make our
company a better version
"of itself today, than it was yesterday?
"How can we create a product this week,
"that's better than the
product we created last week?"
We also have to play the infinite game,
it's not about being ranked number one,
it's not about having
more followers on Twitter,
than your friends, it's
not about outdoing anyone,
it's about how to outdo yourself.
It's not about selling more books
or getting more TED
views than somebody else,
it's about how to make sure
that the work that you're producing
is better than the work
you produced before.
You are your competition
and that is what ensures you
stay in the game the longest
and that is what ensures you find joy,
because the joy comes not from comparison,
but from advantage.
- The concept of improving lives
runs through the center of everything I do
and then I realize
that the way to improve lives
is to continually improve yourself, right,
so with that, every morning
when I get out of the bed,
you know, I haven't fixed
everything in the world yet,
so there's always something to do
and in this film, I read
an interesting quote,
the Siddhartha Gautama,
the Buddha, he said that,
"Good people have to get
out of the bed every day
"and try to empty the ocean with a ladle,"
right, and I thought that was, you know,
I knew that was profound
and I paused for a second
and I said, "Alright,
what the hell is a ladle?"
alright.
(audience laughing)
Right, so then, you know, I
just, I touched it on my Ipad,
it was ladle, oh, it's like a
big spoon, a big spoon, okay,
- [Host] As we say in Philly.
- it was like a soup spoon,
yeah, (laughs) I was like a soup spoon,
I was like, "Why a soup spoon?"
so trying to empty the ocean
with a soup spoon, you know,
as the mentality of how
you wake up every day
to try to do good in the world,
so for me,
- Yeah.
I'm really driven by continually trying
to elevate my mind
and elevate my spirit and care for my body
and to be able to love as many people
as effectively as possible